[Music]
phil is with us in naples florida hi
phil what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help good me too um so
i am in uh baby step four five and six
and i've got a little over ten thousand
dollars in a fidelity roth
um retirement fund and
um just with everything kind of going on
our budget
is a little bit thinner than it used to
be with daycare and just everything else
starting up and uh well just gasoline i
filled up my car this morning about
passed out
well i've got a 2004 f-150 and so that's
uh yeah my raptor man i swear to god i
can buy a house for what i can fill up
the raptor for
it's weird when you're standing at the
gas pump and people are just yelling
biden randomly
yeah there's a lot of stickers around
here on the gas pumps too those are
pretty funny it does make it does make
the budget tight so how can we help
today
well i'm wondering um so with our my
fidelity account uh it seems that i have
to have a 2500 to open up
another mutual fund and so i have over
ten thousand dollars in one mutual final
large cap and
wondering
now that it's a little hard to save you
know twenty five hundred dollars should
i diversify that and put it into three
other
um
mutual funds so now i have the all four
that you guys talked about
um and it's a little easier i guess to
keep investing instead of now saving to
try to invest yeah you don't have to
have 2 500 if you have it on a monthly
draft
and the easiest way to do your roth is
set your set your investments up on a
monthly draft auto drafting your
checking account
instead of doing it lump sum once a
year yeah yeah it just it seemed like
when i had started this it was you had
to have twenty five hundred dollars you
don't
you don't not not to do a monthly draft
to do a single to set up an account and
do a single
occasional investment like once a year
you fund your roth or something in a
lump sum you do what you do with some
mutual funds 2 500 some are a thousand i
think there's two
or three that are 500 minimum some are 5
thousand minimum there's all kinds of
different minimums but uh but yeah
that's what you're running into you can
set it up with almost all of fidelity's
funds
on a monthly auto draft it's an
authorization to draft your checking
account and it's it's easier on you and
it's auto it's automated discipline as
well
yeah for sure okay so there wasn't you
know generally that kind of situation
there wouldn't be
um taxes or fees if i were to try to
diversify
now you can roll it around among all of
those or you could roll it over to just
uh you know you can go get your smart
buster pro
uh one of the folks that we recommend in
that area and they can help you set it
all up and just put it on autopilot but
there is a huge advantage to doing
automatic draft on things that are that
that you know that you are that you want
to
create for me it's automatic discipline
because i forget to do stuff right yeah
and it's also just with the budget
getting tighter he was talking about gas
and inflation and day care and all these
different costs having that automatic
pay yourself first kind of mentality
where it's like you don't have to think
about it you're not debating at the end
of the month don't have enough money to
put into it it's already just
there and going out it's just you will
cut the quote disposable income stuff so
you make your investment yep and you can
still do that i mean so because there's
gas and groceries and that kind of stuff
have not gone up enough yet to
completely squeeze you if you're at baby
step four meaning you don't have any
debt
except a house payment
and so you've got room to do your 15
and eat
even though eating costs more but you
know you may not be going out to eat as
much you may be limiting a vacation you
may be limiting your clothing budget but
you got plenty of clothes
and you know maybe
one less six thousand dollar purse or
whatever i don't know but
uh
you know there's some other stuff but
but you're right you want to
force yourself when things are tight to
continue to be smart right take that
temptation away like take that you know
ability to just use it on something else
and it can be really real needs you know
you might feel at the end of the month
you know i have to stretch my budget for
groceries and these needs that we have
in our household but if you're not
seeing that money and it's going
straight to investments it's just you
know you put your pressure more on your
day-to-day budget versus taking away
from your investing and the way to know
that that's right is
you never missed a car payment
right back when you had a car payment
and so you know you can you know even if
cash prices went up you made your car
payment you figured you just squeezed
out everything some other stuff and
that's that's what you end up doing here
in these situations and hopefully some
of this inflation will
calm down particularly the stuff at the
gas pump eventually